when Gmail was announced Google was very
late to mail service as the algorithm
Microsoft had been on it for more than
five years already most people actually
thought Gmail was a joke as it came out
on April Fool's Day and had absurd
amounts of storage at the time but today
gmail has 1.5 billion users of money as
opposed Yahoo's - or 20 million users a
month
so how was Google able to enter an
established market and take over make
sure to stick around until then to find
out welcome to harvest table UK the
leader of the Gmail team have been
working on Gmail since 1996 he was
trying to create a web-based email which
he worked on for a couple of weeks in
1996 but soon after that he got bored
and quit serious efforts on creating
Gmail weren't initiated onto August of
2001 the first thing that paul added to
the email service was a search engine he
showed to his co-workers and the main
suggestion that he got was that he
should make it so that when you search
it suggested emails as well the search
feature really begged to add some
serious storage to the user experience
but is what are you going to be
searching for if there aren't very many
emails to search through the first place
they wanted to make emails stay forever
at first we thought of some lower limits
like a hundred megabytes which was
generous but not absurd Google really
want your preposterous numbers just 1
gigabyte which is what they had benches
held on because that would really catch
the attention of users however there was
a lot of criticism for Gmail within the
company a lot of employees didn't think
that it was good from a strategic
viewpoint many of them thought that this
had nothing to do with web search at all
and that this is just begging for
Microsoft to come kill them despite that
negativity Larry Page and Sergey Brin
the founders of Google were always by
Gmail side soon enough since you sing
and Kevin Fox are added onto team Kevin
flock to the site of the task of
designing the interface they decided to
use JavaScript instead of HTML like
their competitors base data this would
be much more snappy and responsive it
would feel more like a soft curds
the sequence of websites but there is
definitely things to consider while
using javascript and there is lot
negativity towards this as well this is
because web browsers were really not
good at this time period and they were
worried that JavaScript would crashed a
web browser and finally came the biggest
issue which was Gmail's business model
Paul really wanted to be a free service
as he wanted to reach as many people as
possible he also didn't want to plaster
with the banner ads in the end they
decided on including little text ads now
are derived from content of the email
from the very beginning that you had
Arabi concerns about privacy but to
dismiss this problem as an issue of
perception gmail had been a secret
project evening to go employees until
early 2004 at this point gmail I started
working and Google employees started
using it to access internal company
emails soon enough Google publicly
announced that Gmail will be coming out
on April 1st this was on purpose as it
raised several conversations about the
legitimacy of gmail and this really
spread the word of Gmail they were going
to offer one gigabyte of space which was
unimaginably large in 2004 Sergey wasn't
very excited that on April 1st most
people think that it's a hoax and it was
just a one day thing on April 2nd the
service would be continued to be offered
as George Herrick a Google employee once
said if you're far enough ahead that
people can't forget for a junkie or not
you know you've been emitted there was
one major issue Google couldn't get
computers from their servers on because
people didn't think they could launch
and they couldn't launch because they
couldn't get computers as a result Gmail
ran on 300 all of Pentium 3 computers
that no one wanted but that was enough
power to be able to offer the servers to
about a thousand people and allowing
them each to spread it to a couple of
friends apiece Google was planning on
building Gmail very slowly and meanwhile
on eBay
there were bids up to $150 for a gmail
invite junior became sort of an
exclusive club that was cool to have
they kept increasing the number of
invites that each user could issue until
2007 when they made a public on
Valentine
but it remained Gmail beta until July of
2009 when they were confident that their
service could sufficiently provide for
professionals and businesses while Gmail
was growing very rapidly privacy groups
are not thrilled by it at all
thirty-one organizations and advocates
cosig letter to Sergey Brin and Larry
Page it outlines several concerns about
the service and suggested that the
service be stopped until the concerns
addressed even a Californian senator
sent Google Mail about Gmail of being a
disaster of enormous proportions
she even drafted a bill to make a law
that go had to get consent before scan
emails
however this law was never passed but
glue did react to all this criticism by
applying their policies under Gmail site
and spotlighting journalist quirks that
suggested the controversy about Gmail
was silly these privacy issues persist
even today and Microsoft still uses this
privacy issue as a main way to advertise
outlook despite all of this controversy
Gmail significant growth that had a
better web interface more storage and
advanced search Gmail simply solve all
the issues of its competitors
you not only have to sort through all of
this spam emails or deal with the big
ads and most importantly you didn't have
to periodically delete emails over and
over again you know not on our storage
Gmail was free and offered more storage
capacity than Hotmail and yahoo mail
this was possible because go had a
completely different approach as
competitors Microsoft's business was
really based off of driving revenue
using their monopoly they want to
Microsoft users to use hotmail and drive
revenue through their mail services but
Google had the exact opposite approach
they wanted her new products of support
and increased or monopoly revenue they
wanted Yahoo Mail and hotmail users to
switch over to Gmail and then start
using Google for searching
instead of Yahoo and that is how their a
plan to increase their revenue they do
really care that much about the memory
of gmail itself it's basically as if
Microsoft is trying to attract people
over to Windows by using hotman
and this is why Google offers such great
incentives just a year after lunch they
increased their quota to two gigabytes
per user overall the goal of Gmail
wasn't to make money even they
eventually did become profitable the
goal of Gmail was to drive more traffic
to Google but Gmail ends up doing much
more than just that one more thing
that's very interesting about Gmail is
that it was built to last if you take a
look at today's outlook in yahoo mail
they're completely different from the
original Hotmail and yahoo mail Gmail
has added features at has gone through
some significant redesigns but the
fundamentals of Gmail are identical a
very initial release on top of this
Gmail had a vast implementation across
Internet you can easily log in to
several sites using Gmail you didn't
have to fill out information every
single time while this is a simple idea
it was revolutionary and to save people
a lot of time Gmail was also very quick
to adapt as a quickly launched a Gmail
app after launch of mobile phones in
April of 2019 Gmail and the iPhone mail
app tied in market share at 28 percent
each however the growth of gmail have
led to several concerns for Paul Bukit
himself he believes rising email has
really elected backed social conventions
he says that this is not a technical
problem that can be solved a computer
algorithms but rather a social issue the
rise of email has led to a 24/7 culture
has left people expected responses
despite the time of day whether it's
Saturday at 2:00 a.m.
Arjuna vacation he says that people have
become slaves to email and only those
who use it can fix it after just the
emails fear the growth of Gmail actually
made the whole company of Google much
more confident they realized that they
can dominate something more than just
search and touch all of our lives every
single day this led them to launch
Google Maps just a year later which is
the number one mapping service in the
world today they also powered and heard
about YouTube which is the biggest
operating system in the world
the biggest video sharing site he also
launched Chrome browser which oppositely
destroyed Internet Explorer's dominance
all of these services had 1 billion
users each and these were vastly
successful today Android powers nav 10
smartphones that are shepard globally
gmail also played a big part in google's
10x thinking that one gigabyte was a
hundred times more than what all the
competitors offered if gmail filled they
definitely would not have tried all the
crazy ventures to embark on later such
as self-driving cars and contact lenses
are connected to internet over the years
goula has has issues and have gone under
intense scrutiny by the public and
lawmakers mainly on the privacy issues
but despite all these issues Gmail gave
you the confidence to push through and
continue innovating and today they're
one of the biggest companies in the
world
in the end Gmail completely changed the
trajectory of Google from just offering
search services to completely dominating
Internet and beyond from satellites and
self-driving cars to philipot Jessica's
grew a nexus and of course for glass
Google has been much more ambitious
since Gmail and it is clear they
wouldn't have gotten here without it but
that's all I have for you guys on Gmail
make sure you comment down below what
company are served as you'd like me
also it just like to do the makeup alike
and consider subscribing to more videos
just like this one better then
[Applause]
[Music]